Now, there's another element that you'll
see creeping up into here. So, I'm going
to show you a clip that they did an
interview with the Variety. It's not the
whole thing, but just a portion of the
clip. I think this is very fascinating,
the way they phrased this part of the
conversation.
Who did Ariana see the original stage
show of Wicked with?
This one is boring.
my family. Yeah. Come on.
I remember being so swept off my feet by
just the story and the comedy really
stayed with me when I was little. I
don't think at that point I had seen
anything. I mean, I was 10, but I don't
think I'd seen anything that moved me
that way.
Did you meet Kristen that day? Yeah,
I did. She gave me body gel. She says
it's bath salts, but it was it was body
gel. It had glitter in I think it had
actual witchcraft magic in it. I really
do.
There's no way you get to this without
that witchcraft.
I think it there's a combination of real
magic, manifestation, and hard work
that needs to happen to for things like
this to happen. Don't you think?
I think so.
I'm just thinking of the the
manifestation because it's interesting
that she groups it all together. She's
like real magic, manifestation, and hard
work. I I mean, I agree. I'm sure they
work really hard, you know. I'm sure
they do.
But we understand manifestation as being
a new age concept.
You know, we did a whole show on this of
of this this guy who basically left
Christianity and how did he get into
manifestation, which is um another term
for it is um the law of attraction. The
law of attraction. Yeah. So he said the
reason he got into it was because of
thinking and growing yourself rich. and
the book The Secret,
you know, it's this whole idea of like I
I want it and so I'm going to meditate
on it and it's going to appear in my
life
as in you are the one in control making
that thing happen.
Yes. Yes.
So very interesting. Uh just kind of a
tangent but from history. Where does the
law of attraction come from?
I don't know. Good question.
You don't know?
No. I don't think
Oh, fascinating. So, it's credited as
being um first written about from a lady
named Helena Blavatzki.
Oh, didn't know that.
Really?
Yes.
Major.
So, major occultist. Blavotsky wrote
about this in the 1800s now in some
research I'm doing on for a long-term
project. I mean, I've been looking at
this for like probably close to 10 years
now. um which have not published this
yet.
But Blavski, the year that she's
credited with writing that and using
that term, she's actually not the first
person in literature I found to use
that.
So the first time it actually appears in
literature is 10 years prior to the
claim that Bloatsky published it
and it was written down by a man named
Andrew Jackson Davis.
Was he also an oultist?
You could say that. Yes, because he was
somebody who
he kind of drew inspiration from two
sources of people. One was the Shakers
and another one was a man by the name of
Emanuel Swedenborg.
And Andrew Jackson Davis was this very
strange story. He basically was not he
didn't have a high school education,
but he
you know had predicted the speed of
light.
like 80 years before it was calculated.
He predicted like automobiles and
he um
claimed to have communicated with past
individuals from history. He was the one
very fascinating tidbit from history.
Andrew Jackson Davis was the one who had
a journal. Um he was you could say
essentially communicating with the other
side. in his journal on March 31, 1848,
there was an entry that said, um,
"Brother, the good work has begun."
Okay, it's like, well, that's kind of
random. What kind of work does that have
to do with that? The good the good work
has begun.
That was the same date. And then that
night in the same part of the country
that the Fox sisters first heard
the rapping and started communicating
with Mr. Splitfoot.
Well, you have to maybe give a little
one-s sentence brief description who the
Fox sisters are for those who don't
spiritualist
were Yeah. a group of sisters who um
they essentially toured the US and parts
of Europe
claiming to communicate with the dead.
Yep.
And that was first done in their home
in New York. Right.
In New York. And today at their home you
can find a plaque that says
um you know there is no death, there are
no dead. And it was that plaque was put
there by the spiritualists of the world.
They date it you know talk about their
philosophy. But anyway, that's like a
whole another tangent. It's a whole
another topic. I'm hoping to produce a
documentary on that whole thing
at some point in the future because
there's a ton of information about
spiritualism and all these people that
are connected and
scientists and historical figures and
what they believed, what they were
trying to accomplish, all of that.
So anyway, total tangent, right?
Getting back to this
very interesting choice of words. Like
why would you even say that?
And not only that, she has claimed that
she's a a witch herself. The wicked
the wickedest witch.
The wickedest witch. So
I would imagine she knows a thing or two
about what she's talking about.
She uses tarot cards on set of wicked.
But but also if you think about it, the
law of attraction, right, and how deeply
it is actually connected to oultism and
spiritualism. Lavodzka, whom you
mentioned, she's an open worshipper of
Lucifer, of Satan.
Um, but the Bible clearly speaks against
witchcraft as well, which should be a
reason in the first place for Christians
not to watch this. But exactly,
it it so witchcraft is from Satan. Um,
the law of attraction or manifestation
or manifesting is from Satan.
Yeah.
And so it's like she just puts
everything together.
If it's coming from Blovadsky, it's not
coming from God. I mean, she has
statements like in the secret doctrine.
I think it's on page 79 where she says
um
she says something like uh she's talking
about Lucifer the lightbearer
and um how he had to be sacrificed
to the new nog the new dogma because he
is older and higher than Jehovah.
I mean that's just that's what she said.
So if she's talking of promoting
something like the law of attraction,
you can I can guarantee you it's not
coming from God.
[Music]
Jacob
and he for you is
make him a pillar in the temple of my
God and he shall go out no more. I will
ride on him the name of my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the power
shall strength. He shall mount the
demons like he shall run and not
alone. But by every word that proceeds
from the mouth of God,
it's interesting that you mentioned
these things about what the Bible says
to say about witchcraft, right? We know
from Deuteronomy 18 10-12 says there
shall not be found among you anyone who
makes his son or daughter pass through
the fire or one who practices witchcraft
or a soussayer or one who interprets
omens or a sorcerer or one who conjures
spells or a medium or a spiritist or one
who calls up the dead for all who do
these things are an abomination to the
Lord and because these abominations the
Lord your God drives them out from
before you. You go on to read that
passage. It says, you know, the Lord has
not given these things to you.
Something like that. I'm kind of
paraphrasing,
but it's not just something that was in
the Old Testament.
No.
That it's like, okay, well, that was for
Christians then or Israelites then. It
it doesn't apply to Christianity today.
No, no, no. Entirely false. The Bible
says in Revelation 2:18, Felipe,
"But the cowardly, unbelieving,
abominable, murderers, sexually immoral,
sorcerers, idoltors,
and all liars shall have their part in
the lake which burns with fire and
brimstone, which is the second death."
So clearly, Old Testament, New
Testament, both agree. Sorcerers,
witchcraft, soothsayers,
that's right. all of that,
those people,
God finds that abomination
and they are not going to be found in
the kingdom of God. That's not to say
people who used to do that can't come
out of that and be converted.
Absolutely.
They're not beyond the reach of God,
right?
But if they continue to persist in those
activities, then God will say, "There's
no place for you in my kingdom because I
have strictly forbidden this." It's
impersonating the voice of God to God's
people if you think about it because God
communicates through prophets by the
power of the Holy Spirit and gives
messages. Well, this is like Satan's
counterfeit for that.
So, you can understand where God would
say, "This is strictly forbidden. I
cannot have this
because it's too confusing for people.
It would lead them astray."
Yep.
So, we talked about how do we know
what's good and what's
not good? You need to have a compass of
morality.
You do.
You can't just because we live in a time
and place um in postmodernism where
there's this idea of everybody has their
own sense of morality of of what is
right and what is wrong. That just
destroys humility.
Mhm. Because if you think that it is
right to practice witchcraft or um to to
commit the most abominable crimes, then
you can say, "Oh, I can just do that and
there is no law against me." Right? When
But when we have a compass like the
Bible, we know this is what is right and
this is what is best for humanity and
we're all on the same page. Not just
because we're all on the same page, but
we're doing all the wicked stuff. We're
all on the same page. actually genuinely
loving God and loving each other
without a a
straight definition of morality on
what's good and evil. It's up to each
person to decide what's good.
So, who am I to tell you you shouldn't
steal because that's not good,
right?
And you go on and say, "Oh, it's good.
I'm doing it for a reason. I think the
reason is good."
Yeah.
Right. Well, that's why we need the
Bible. Like like you were saying,
the Bible says in Romans 13:10-12
that
none of us are actually good.
That's right.
There's none good. None who does good.
No, not one.
Like we're all in this condition where
none of us apart in our in our own
selves, we will tend towards sin. And so
we need God
to
to essentially do good. Now people can
do nice things. They can do good things.
But the Bible also indicates that all of
that if anyone does anything good, it
comes from God.
Whether you are believing in God or not,
he's saying I am the one that is able to
help people do those things whether they
realize who's working in their life or
not.
But essentially there's there's there's
nobody that is good. this idea that
they're putting out in this film that
they've been changed for good because
they have this relationship. We also see
that
there's this mixing of light and
darkness.
Is that what they portray? Like like
Cynthia Aria's characters like the bat
witch and Ariana Grand characters like
the good witch.
I see the yin-yang system. She, you
know, Alaba is getting frustrated
because she believes that what she is
doing is good.
But it's it's quite fascinating. You saw
in the trailer, this is the wizard is
lying to us.
Alphaba is the green
the green witch. Yeah.
Why is that bad,
right? If there is no standard for
morality and how do you define morality?
How do you know that? Why? Why is lying
a problem?
Mhm. Right.
So, she gets frustrated because she
believes everything she's trying to do
is good
and it's not appreciated.
And so, then she essentially makes a vow
that she's not going to do good anymore.
Okay.
And all of her tactics are not going to
be good moving forward.
Well, then how can you call that good
consider? How can somebody like that
change somebody else,
right,
to be good? I mean, there's all kinds of
like questions that swirl.
Yeah.
When you're talking about, well, what's
good and what's not good and how they
change and what they decide to do and
not not do and
the sides that they take,
you know, being pitted against each
other like that with this mixing of
light and darkness. Would you read 1
John 5:7? just uh Felipe this is what
the Bible says about
light and darkness
1 John 1:5-7 says this is the message
which we have heard from him and
declared to you that God is light and in
him is no darkness at all. If we say
that we have fellowship with him and
walk in darkness, we lie and do not
practice the truth. But if we walk in
the light as he is in the light, we have
fellowship with one another. And the
blood of Jesus Christ, his son, cleanses
us from all sin
in order for us to have light or be in
the light. We have to walk in the light
as he is in the light. That's very
clear.
Mhm.
There there's no two ways about this.
God is light. In him is no darkness at
all.
Amen.
There's no mixing of these two. That's
right. which is especially important
with the next point I'm going to share.
So, this is the fandom page for the
Wicked movie and it's talking about this
song for good, right? There's a quote I
found on this page
and it says, "This song is performed
towards the end of the musical." Okay,
this this for good, you know, that that
has the double meaning, right? In it,
the two are singing farewell to one
another. So, they the farewell is we've
changed each other for good.
Mhm. and permanently.
Just prior to the song, Alaba gives
Glenda the grimmory and tells her that
it is up to her to continue Alaba's
cause.
What's the grim?
Oh, that's a fascinating question, isn't
it? So, this is the grimmorary.
Okay.
This was in the trailer. Did you see
this?
I noticed something. I I can't I still
can't.
You saw it in the trailer.
In the lyrics to the song for this, it
um talks about what good is this
chanting. You heard chanting in the
trailer. Do you remember? She said these
words that you probably didn't
understand like what language is that?
That's chanting. As soon as I saw that
and heard that, I was like, "Oh boy."
It's like basically make the hair on the
back of your neck stand up.
She's casting a spell.
Mhm.
In the trailer, in the movie. Come on,
guys. Now, what are the what are the
words? The the words are made up from
different languages. I don't
remember what it meant. Uh it had
something to do with the story line, but
the point is she's casting a spell and
they're passing the baton from one
person to the next is she's giving her
the grim.
Okay. What is the grimmory?
I want to point out real quick because I
know where you're going with this.
Yes. And I want to point out that this
looks like a bunch of sun rays.
It does look like a bunch of sun rays.
And you notice in here there's a bunch
of symbols.
Yes.
Okay. You can see them in in various
parts of the screenshot.
Okay. What's a grim
wicked fandom? Again, this is their
their stuff. Like I didn't make this up.
The grimmory, known on earth as the
lesser key of Solomon, is a magical
spell book or grimmoire of magnificent
power which Alaba finds in the attic of
Kimo Co and was later given to her by
Serema. Alaba can only read parts of it
as the book originates from the other
world which is Earth. The book also
created Yakal to be a guardian to the
book and a witness to the tragic life of
Alaba.
Do you know what the lesser key of
Solomon is?
No.
Okay. Well, let's find out.
I I recognize Solomon.
I know about the lesser key of Solomon
from working here many years. Scotty has
talked about this many times.
The Lesser Key of Solomon is a grimoire
or a text of magical incantations. In
fact, this is one of the most
known or or comprehensive books on
magic.
The Lesser Key of Solomon.
Like it's an actual thing. It's an
actual thing.
Oh.
So, it's a text of magical incantations
and spells that are said to have been
written by King Solomon. Actually,
nobody believes that, but that's what
it's called. Even people that practice
all this stuff, they know it's not
written by Solomon, who is a legendary
figure in Jewish, Islamic, and Christian
traditions, right? The text is divided
into five books. And the second book
known as the Ar Godia is one that is
famous for its description of the 72
demons and their corresponding sigils.
Interesting. So yeah, there are 72
beings that are listed in this book as
demons
that people claim to have communicated
with and named.
And there is a symbol for each one of
them
to invoke that specific demon for a
specific reason, for a specific thing.
And this is all in a familyfriendly
movie.
I mean, it is. It goes on. says
according to the text the 72 demons were
summoned by King Solomon and bound to
his will so that he could use their
powers for various purposes. Now that's
fascinating and Solomon would have known
about power both ways if you read the
Bible. He would have known about the
power of God and he would have known
that that is more powerful. So why
resort to this?
But we also know that Solomon did dabble
in things of the occult. Each demonic
spirit is associated with a specific
sigil, a symbol or a seal representing
the demon's name and power. It goes on
to say, "The sigils are said to be
powerful tools for summoning and
commanding the demons. They still should
only be used by experienced
practitioners of magic as they can be
dangerous if misused.
In fact, the text warns that the demon
should not be summoned for idle
curiosity or frivolous reasons as they
can be unpredictable and even harmful.
Okay.
H
lesser key of Solomon. What's in it?
There are many contributors to this
through since probably like the 14th
century or so. One of the later
contributors to this was Samuel Lidell
McGregor Mathers. He was one of the
last. In fact, he he worked with another
individual. Um, but he compiled a lot of
the information, but it was um published
I'll tell you who it was published by in
a second, but this is the very first
paragraph of the lesser key of Solomon.
Okay, Denique, would you read this? It
is lofty amusing to the student of
magical literature who is not quite a
fool and rare is such a combination to
note the criticism directed by the
Philistine against the citadel of his
science. Truly since our childhood has
ingrained into us not only literal
belief in the Bible but also substantial
belief in elf Leila W Leila and only
adolescence can cure us. We are only too
liable in the Russian energy of dawning
manhood to overturn roughly and rashly
both these classics to regard them both
on the same level as interesting
documents from the standpoint of
folklore and anthropology and as nothing
more. So they're saying the Bible
and that other book which I think is
Arabian Knights,
right? They're saying those are on the
same level as interesting documents from
the standpoint of folklore and
anthropology and as nothing more. And
this is in the lesser key of Solomon.
Lesser key of Solomon. Okay. Bible.
Not really. That's
just fall.
Even though the Bible is the one Even
though the Bible is the one that
confirms that Solomon existed.
Yeah, I know. Good point. Right. Put it
all in perspective.
This is the book that Alaba has that
she's casting a spell from to release
Prince Fiero, I think. and the book that
she's also handing off to Glenda to
continue to promote her cause.
So, this book is central to their
relationship
and cause.
Now, you're I don't know if you have
this on here, but you were showing me
like a seal of Baal that was somehow
connected to the the lesser key of
Solomon, right?
Yes. Baal is the first demon.
Okay. first name, Bill.
Sigil number one.
Mhm.
It reminded me of another symbol. I
There's no way I could conclusively say
that those two things are related, but
when I saw it, I was like, "Wow, that
actually looks like the Vatican
emblem."
Mhm.
I just wanted to point it out because
the Bale was a a god of sun worship.
Yes. and then her grim had all of the
rays coming out of it and stuff.
Now, there are some people that
correlate Baal the demon with Baal the
god in the Bible,
but there are some that do not. They are
not necessarily
the same thing according according to
occult people.
Okay,
I see.
Now, it might be, it might not. I don't
know. I think you could probably dig and
determine that
whether it is or not. Either way, Baal
was known for like they would sacrifice
their children to Baal. And so if in the
Bible Yeah. Yeah. And in history too. So
if that is the case, let's just
say it is the case that
this Baal is the same as in the book,
which this book is used in the movie.
Yeah.
That's very disturbing. It is very
disturbing and and odd that they have
basically the same name. Like there's a
demon named Baal and then there's this
character in the Bible that
has all these abominable activities,
right? A false god in the Bible.
Yeah. A false god.
Uh the Bible does say I think it's Paul
that says, you know, the um the gods
that they worshiped or the gods that
they sacrificed to, they sacrificed to
demons,
you know. So it's like, well,
yeah. you know. Anyway, so Mathers was
the last person who was compiling
information from this book, but it was
published by
Alistister Crowley.
This the Lakia Solomon.
Yes. In 1904.
Wait, he he published the book.
He published the book. He was the editor
and published the book.
So Alistister Crowley, Satanist,
magician.
Yes. and like vile vile vow. He says
right there, the wickedest man in the
world.
And that was the press of the day.
Fascinating term though that they called
him the wickedest
man.
Yep.
In the world.
Yeah.
He he wrote a book called um the book of
the law.
Mhm.
Has all kinds of anti-Christian
things in it. I think I think the book
of the law is the one where we have the
quote where he says do as thou wilt as
the whole of the law.
But that's interesting going back to
wicked where they take away the the
moral compass and it's like there is no
moral compass anywhere. You do whatever
you want to do and what you think is
good is good. What you think is evil is
evil. That really goes back to what
Alistister Carly is saying. Do what thou
wilt should be the whole of the law.
Yeah. He wrote another book. I'm trying
to remember what it's called. was like
blood blood sex and magic or something
like that.
Um
yeah, he he wrote many books largely in
the realm of the occult and he was not
known to be somebody you would want as a
next door neighbor. We'll just put it
that way.
Yeah. You probably won't make it out
alive.
Yeah. So he Yeah. He was a very evil
evil man.
So, another fascinating
um point I discovered when when looking
this up specifically when it came to
sigils
and there was a book called the book of
lies, the diff information guide to
magic and the occult. And it has a lot
of contributors. So people that are
they're pulling from as um sources of
authority
to clear up people's misunderstandings
about what magic is and what what it's
not.
You can see the list of people that are
on here. Grant Morrison,
Alistister Crowley,
Grant Morrison is a comic book author.
Yeah. Anton Ley, he founded the Church
of Satan in the US. So these are
these are some heavy hitters, right, in
the occult.
Well, in Grant Morrison's portion, he
talks about sigils.
Mhm.
Okay. His his section is called like pop
magic or whatever. Um, so this is what
he says. In the pop magic style, the
sigil is the first and one of the most
effective of all weapons in the arsenal
of any modern magician. The sigil
technique was reconceptualized and
modernized by Austin Osman spare in the
early 20th century and popularized by
chaos magicians in the temple of psychic
youth in the 1980s.
A sigil is a magically charged symbol
like this one. Then he gives an example
which that is probably one from the
lesser key of Solomon. He goes on to say
that the sigil takes a magical desire or
intent. Let's say it's my desire to be a
great actor. You can and of course put
any desire you want in there. What is
this starting to sound like?
Do with that will chubby to hold the
law.
What else? The law of attraction,
right? Okay. Yes. Yeah.
And folds it down creating a highly
charged symbol. The desire is then
forgotten. Only the symbol remains and
you can then be charged to full potency
when the magician chooses. Forgetting
the desire in its verbal form can be
difficult. He says if started too
ambitiously.
There's no point charging a symbol to
win the lottery if you don't buy a
ticket. So, they're saying, "Yeah, you
need the sigil, but you also need to act
on it." Which is the same thing they
teach in the law of attraction.
Mhm.
Right.
Yeah. That's that's pretty much
manifesting right there.
So, start with stuff that's not too
emotionally involving. He says, "I
sigilize to meet people I'm interested
in or for particular qualities I'll need
in a given situation. I've also used
sigils for healing.
Fascinating. For locating lost objects
and for mass global change. What do all
those things have in common?
What would you say?
Cue the Jeopardy music. Right.
Mhm.
Those are things I'd pray about.
Oh,
right.
Lose your keys, can't find them, couple
hours, you pray about it. Right.
That's a good point.
Somebody that needs to be healed,
you pray about it.
Global change, you pray about it.
Mhm. Right. I don't have any power.
God has power.
That's true. Yeah.
So he says, "I've been using them for 20
years and they always
work." This is Grant Morrison.
Now, now, now Keith, I mean, you lose
your keys
and let's say you haven't prayed about
it. Are you just going to sit there and
like, uh, I'm going to find my keys like
that? No. You have to search and search
and search and and even when you pray
doesn't mean God doesn't have the power
but sometimes he allows you to go
through that moment like
personally
sometimes it's really irritating when I
find lose my keys and that's a moment of
reflection of like
thank you Lord for using this
opportunity to teach me character growth
right there's reasons why God doesn't
always allow to
uh answer the prayer immediately and
then in in this case it's like
there's another force at play clearly
that will just like we'll help you find
your keys.
Here's your keys. You know, immediate
instant gratification which God is the
opposite of that because he wants to you
to see to search your heart to show your
character even in the little things like
not finding your keys.
Yeah. So he goes on and I know this is
like a long section but I think the
context is important.
Mhm. So the last thing he says says for
me the period between launching the
signal the sigil and its manifestation
as a realworld event is usually 3 days 3
weeks or three months depending on the
variables involved.
So if he wants to meet somebody 3 days 3
weeks three months
and then he repeats he says I repeat
sigils always work. M
so this is like to debunk what people
think about magic. He's talking about
symbols and he's like this is the real
deal. I use this all the time.
This is how they work.
It's accurate
and they always work.
Yeah.
And this is how part of the occult
operates.
I want to end on something that the
Bible says. It comes from Ephesians
chapter 5 8-14. So, I'm going to ask um
you two to read this in closing.
For you were once darkness, but now you
are light in the Lord. Walk as children
of light. For the fruit of the spirit is
in all goodness, righteousness, and
truth, finding out what is acceptable to
the Lord, and have no fellowship with
the unfruitful works of darkness, but
rather expose them. For it is shameful
even to speak of those things which are
done by them in secret. But all things
that are exposed are made manifest by
the light. For whatever makes manifest
is light. Therefore, he says, "Awake you
who sleep, arise from the dead, and
Christ will give you light."
Paul wrote this to a church that was
steeped into the occult once upon a
time. The Ephesians were the ones that
had the magic books that were burned.
They were used to seeing an this kind of
activity. They had come out of that and
his advice to them is don't have
anything to do with that anymore. In
fact, expose that kind of stuff. It's
not from God. You need to walk in the
light.
Amen.
And not with this other stuff. So, as
Christians, we see this. This is in a
film that is marketed to families.
Mhm.
We should have nothing to do with this.
That's right.
Because it's only promoting occult
ideals, occult philosophies, and things
that are not going to put us on the path
to heaven. So, be careful what you
watch. You don't always know what's
going into the thought process behind it
or what they're putting into it or why.
And it looks like it's just a story
about friendship, but it's a whole lot
more you're g than that is what you're
getting.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh,
no. I don't know what to say.
[Music]